the Karmann Ghia was Volkswagens
high-fashion model in its day though the
sports coupe aid came in for criticism
many said its driving performance was no
match for its racy looks still after
production ceased in 1974 the Karmann
Ghia became an instant classic which has
only increased in value
he sits again our Chester says he's
sitting in a heartbreaker of a car a
real dreamboat and the most beautiful VW
ever built that Karmann Ghia elegant and
fragile with thin chrome pipes for
bumpers the Karmann Ghia looked like it
belong on a merry-go-round rather than
on the street car bodybuilder Carmen
created the first prototype for the
coupe a based on the platform of the VW
Beetle in 1953 production started two
years later peated metal ivory colored
nobs imitation leather and three gauges
dominate the minimalistic cockpit at the
back the most powerful of the Beatles
engines hums the first one said just 30
horsepower later ones 50 as a secret
stuff Bauer says the car looks sporty
and zippier than it actually is
when it came out in 1955 it only had a
30 horsepower motor and took Christoph
half a minute to get the car to go from
0 to 100 kilometers an hour he says it's
just a gussied up VW but in 1955 the
Ghia was powerful enough to keep
vehicles like the go-go mobile and BMW
is set to in check today the car just
goes with the flow giving drivers enough
time to consider little details like
it's typically VW smell and it's in
different directional stability
christophe says it's wonderfully
relaxing to drive this car and that she
noticed the cars robust technology still
the steering wheel is very delicate and
those with big hands like his tend to
hold it with just their fingertips but
the horn is the real attention-getter he
says
is that nice yes what characterizes the
early model Carmen Diaz is there in the
middle feeling of quality workmanship
isn't the Karmann Ghia wonderful our
tester enthuses adding that it's the
most graceful sports car of the 1950's
he notes that it doesn't have the showy
radiator grilles of the Mercedes 190 or
[ __ ] warred Isabella ku pays but he says
the key is not really a sports car
because under its wonderful body is
standard beetle technology in this case
a one and a half liter boxer engine from
1966 which is 44 horsepower Christoph
says while the Kia won't win races
it does win hearts especially once as
lovely is this in original condition
it's got just 33,000 kilometers on the
clock now he's taking this exceptional
model out for a spin
this Karmann Ghia is from the automobile
milestones collection at the site House
Museum in wolf sport the sporting Ghia
Kupe was the first to offer elegant
Italian design at an affordable price
this was made possible by combining the
Jia's sheet metal body with
cost-effective series production
technology christophe says the car was
mocked as being a Porsche for rich
housewives and even impostor but if the
Karmann Ghia was an imposter it was a
very successful one it was produced for
close to 20 years during which time
443,000 coupe pays and convertibles were
sold our tester says those are sales
figures many real sports cars and only
dream of and these days many people can
only dream of owning a car mid-year
convertibles in mint condition so for
over twenty five thousand euros while
COO pays change hands for around 18,000
not bad for a beetle variant that
originally sold for just over 3500 euros
our tester calls the Karmann Ghia the
perfect car for people who like to look
sharp and have time to spare personally
he like a few more horsepower that he
says the cars wonderful design
compensates for a lot and makes this car
a truth automotive milestone